speaking of which
i got to ask you about computer science
yeah that's right i do some of that
so i mean a lot of it a lot of your work
is what inspired this
deep thinking about productivity from
all the different
angles because some of the most rigorous
work is mathematical work
and in computer science that theoretical
computer science
let me ask the scott anderson question
of like is is there something
to you that stands out in particular
that's beautiful or inspiring
or just really insightful about computer
science or the
or maybe mathematics i mean i like
theory
and in particular what i've always liked
in theory is the notion of
impossibilities
that's kind of my specialty so within
the
within the context of distributed
algorithms my specialty is impossibility
results the idea that you can argue
nothing exists that solves this or
nothing exists that can solve this
faster than this and that's i think
that's really interesting and that goes
all the way back to turin
there's his original paper on computable
numbers
with their connection to that it's in
german the islip tongue problem but
basically the german
name that hilbert called the decision
problem this was pre-computers
but he was you know he's english so it's
written in english so it's very
accessible paper
and it's it lays the foundation for all
of theoretical computer science he just
has this insight
he's like well if we think about like an
algorithm i mean he figures out like all
effective procedures or turing machines
or basically algorithms we could really
describe a turing machine with a number
which we can now imagine with like
computer code you could just take a
source file and just
treat the binary version of the file as
like a really long number right
but it's like every program is just a
finite number it's a natural number
and then he realized like one way to
think about a problem is you have
and this is like kind of the mike sipser
approach but you have a sort of
uh it's a language so of an infinite
number of strings some of them are in
the language and some of them aren't but
basically you can imagine a problem is
represented as an infinite binary string
where in every position like a one means
that string is in the language and zero
means it isn't
and then he applied cantor from the 19th
century
and said okay the natural numbers are
countable so it's accountably infinite
and infinite binary strings you can use
a diagonalization argument to show
they're they're
uh they're uncountable so there's just
vastly more problems than there are
algorithms so basically anything you can
come up with for the most part almost
certainly is not solvable by a computer
you know and then and then he was like
let me give a particular example and he
figured out the very first computability
proof and he said let's just walk
through with a little bit of simple
logic
the halting problem can't be solved by
an algorithm and that kicked off the
whole
enterprise of some things can't be
solved by
algorithms some things can't be solved
by computers and we've just been doing
theory on that
since the that was the 30s he wrote that
so proving that something is impossible
uh is sort of a more a stricter version
of that is it like proving bounds on
on the performance of different
algorithms so those are yeah so bounds
are upper bounds right so you say
uh this algorithm does at least this
well and no worse than this but you're
looking at a particular algorithm
and possibility proof say no algorithm
ever
could ever solve this problem so no
algorithm could ever solve the halting
problem
so it's problem-centric it's it's making
something diff
making a conclusive statement about the
problem
and that's somehow satisfying because
it's uh just philosophically interesting
yeah i mean it all goes back to you you
get back to plato it's all
uh reductio ad absurdum so all these
arguments have to start the only way to
do it is there's an infinite number of
solutions you can't go through them as
you say let's assume
for the sake of contradiction that there
existed something that solves this
problem
and then you turn the crank of logic
until you blow up the universe and then
you go back and say okay our original
assumption
that this solution exists can't be true
i i just think philosophically it's like
a
really exciting kind of beautiful thing
it's what i specialize in within
distributed algorithms is
more like time-bound and possibility
results like no
no algorithm can solve this problem
faster than this in this setting
of all the infinite number of ways you
might ever do it
you